shock and disbelief
outside a school inside a lone teenager
had run a mark
shooting indiscriminately the reality
had
shattered a normal teaching day in the
building known simply as school
175 unsurprisingly there was
panic some of the students had run for
cover
teachers had slammed doors shut
at least two students had jumped out of
windows
others were able to wait until emergency
teams
rescued them the security forces heavily
armed
and in large numbers arrived quickly and
arrested the suspected killer
he's reported to be 19 years old and a
registered gun owner
it's unclear what motive he had for the
attack
some eyewitnesses say it wasn't only
gunshots that they heard
there was one explosion or maybe two
there was a strong bang
we jumped up and thought it was a truck
then we heard alarms and ran out
it isn't clear whether the noise was
action being taken by the security
forces
or the attacker but there was debris
both
inside and outside the building scenes
of school shootings may be almost
commonplace in the united states
in russia they're rare and shortly after
the attack came a statement from the
kremlin
president vladimir putin had appointed
the head of the national guard to
immediately look
at imposing new stricter controls over
the types of weapons in use by civilians
how and why such an attack happened in a
school that didn't even have any
security
is being investigated andrew simmons al
jazeera